the eu's drug regulator is expected to
authorize the first covert 19 vaccines
for the omicron variant although they do
not target the latest strains
the adapted vaccines made by biotech
pfizer and moderna will be discussed at
a meeting of the european medicines
agency on thursday this comes a day
after u.s health officials approved
updates to covert 19 vaccines that do
target the latest strains of the omicron
variant the tweaked booster shots could
be available in the u.s in a matter of
days eu authorities say they hope to
approve a separate fisa vaccine adapted
for the latest omicron types in the fall
here's more on why covert 19 vaccines
needed an update and how it's been done
to help fight off covet 19 vaccines
induce defensive measures in the body
among them are the production of
protective antibodies that can recognize
and latch on to the surface of the
coronavirus especially its spike protein
that can stop the virus from docking
onto cells to infect them and flag it up
for destruction by other immune system
defenders
but if the structure of the spike
protein changes due to mutation it can
have consequences
the immune system might no longer
quickly recognize the invader
omicron
has
over time adapted to become all the more
efficient
for infecting human cells there are a
number of parameters and characteristics
that make it a really difficult
virus to deal with
one of which is because it has changed
some of its surface
structure by a mutation and the spike
has a number of changes
mrna vaccines use snippets of genetic
code to make the body produce the spike
protein to stimulate an immune response
to sars cov2 rewriting the code is a
pretty fast and straightforward process
and changing it changes the vaccine's
associated spike protein so why have
omicron specific vaccines taken so long
to arrive
this has a lot to do
with two factors
factor one we're not sure
that better
adapting and refining the vaccine is
genuinely going to afford
a market improvement
in protecting against
future infections
and then of course
at the level of the manufacturer
decisions have to be made
when do we bite the bullet and actually
now produce a new vaccine
experts hope messenger rna vaccine
technology will help us keep pace with
new variants of sarsko v2 as the virus
continues to evolve
and here to break down the fda's
authorization of these news vaccines is
derek williams from dw science so what
is different about these new ones well
mrna vaccines they they act kind of like
software that's that's the the
comparison that's often that's often
made and in that sense if you if you if
you pursue that particular picture then
these are kind of patches on the
software of the original mrna vaccines
that that were made back in 2021 um
they're they're tuned to create
not the spike protein from the original
ancestral
virus which
was first discovered in juhan but
instead tuned to the ba-4 and ba-5
sub-variants of omicron which are the
highly infectious sub-variants that are
currently hitting
nations all over the world and so so
it's an update in that sense it's a
patch on the software and but it's it's
also it's it's not there's there's
another aspect of it as well which is
that the original formulations are going
to continue to be in these new vaccines
it's what's called a bivalent vaccine so
they're adding an extra
ingredient to the mix if you will
does this make them more effective and
and even safer or what's the case well i
don't i don't think that there's any
issues
or questions really great questions
about the safety um these these mrna
vaccines have been given to hundreds of
millions of people now and the platform
has proven to be safe and since the
change that's being made is not really
fundamentally to the platform it's more
of what you would think of as a cosmetic
change to the to the makeup of the
vaccine itself um i don't think that
people are worried about about the
safety issues the effectiveness still
remains to be seen because this is all
you know
really we're pretty far ahead of the
curve in terms of we're still reacting
to omicron
but we're we're we're having to do
things in a very very fast way faster
than we've ever actually done them
before and so we don't have a lot of
effectiveness data yet
in mice keeping keeping ahead is the the
hardest part isn't it because i mean we
we could be in for another variant at
some stage or another strain over well
that's that's actually to be expected
we've we've seen what four variants now
that that have succeeded so we're
getting one about every six months and
omicron has been around now since last
november since 10 months so so experts
are really expecting a new variant to
pop up possibly as early as this winter
although
you know nobody can predict the future
but this doesn't put us behind it keeps
us ahead well
well it's what it's doing is it's
keeping us on track we've been we've
been reacting to these to these changes
in the virus uh too late and and too
slowly and and that's the strength of
this particular platform the mrna maxine
platform which is that it allows us to
react much more quickly to changes in
the virus but but we still have to
get those things on track and and
production as we just heard also in that
piece is is a big issue
is that speed
factor the the the key to ending the
pandemic well ending the pandemic is
going
it doesn't matter how good the vaccines
are and how quickly we can produce them
if people don't take them and i think
vaccine fatigue is starting to play a
really big role we've got these
wonderful new vaccines and everybody
expects them to
to to do a particular job but people
still have to take them and i think that
that's going to prove to be a big
problem moving forward derek williams dw
science thank you very much for getting
your take on the story